un acuerdo económico pero ante todo un
hito en la lucha de las víctimas de la
violencia armada en eeuu remington arms
pagará 73 millones de dólares a las
familias de cinco adultos y cuatro niños
asesinados en una de las peores masacres
en la historia reciente del país sandy
hook es una llaga aún abierta en el alma
estadounidense fue el 14 de diciembre de
2012 en una escuela primaria de newtown
connecticut cuando un joven de 20 años
adam lanza utilizó un rifle ar-15 de
remington para acabar con la vida de 20
niños inocentes 6 adultos y hasta de su
propia madre
dif hoy marcó un punto de inflexión
cuando nuestro deber de cuidar a
nuestros niños como sociedad finalmente
reemplaza el resultado final de una
industria que para empezar hizo posible
una atrocidad como sandy hook hoy es un
día de responsabilidad para una
industria que ha disfrutado mucho
operando con inmunidad e impunidad
redding webb de ti
el caso se centró en la comercialización
del arma bushmaster ar-15 que
originalmente se fabricó para el combate
pero que fue publicitada como una
máquina efectiva para matar en 2005 se
vendieron 100 mil y 2 millones en 2012
no fue utilizada por un soldado
altamente capacitado sino por un niño
con problemas profundos no en un campo
de batalla en el extranjero sino en una
escuela de primaria en casa y no para
preservar las libertades sino para
destripar las williams
fueron años de intensa lucha judicial
para estas familias que demandaron en
2014 y desde entonces los actos de
violencia con armas de fácil acceso
sigue sin dar tregua según un estudio
reciente de todos los tiroteos masivos
que tuvieron lugar entre 1966 y 2019 más
de la mitad ocurrieron a partir del año
2000 y el 20% de ellos ocurrió entre
2010 y 2019